let's go back for a sec
to uh to a comma and
how what you know for people who are
curious to try it out
how do you install a comma in say a 2020
toyota corolla or like
what are the cars that are supported
what are the cars that you recommend
and what does it take you have a few
videos out but maybe through words can
you explain
what's it take to actually install a
thing so we support uh i think it's 91
cars 91 makes models
um we could get to 100 this year nice
the yeah the 2020
corolla great choice the um
2020 sonata uh it's using the stock
longitudinal it's using just our lateral
control
but it's a very refined car their
longitudinal control is not
bad at all um so yeah corolla
sonata or if you're willing to get your
hands a little dirty and look in the
right places on the internet the honda
civic is great
uh but you're going to have to install a
modified eps firmware
in order to get a little bit more torque
and i can't help you with that comma
does not officially endorse that
but we have been doing it we didn't ever
release it
uh we waited for someone else to
discover it and then you know
and you have a discord server where
people there's a very active
developer community as opposed to so
depending on the level of
experimentation you're willing to
to do that's the community if you
if you just want to buy it and you have
a supported car yeah
it's 10 minutes to install there's
youtube videos
it's ikea furniture level if you can set
up a table from ikea
you can install a comma 2 in your
supported car and it will just work
now you're like oh but i want this
high-end feature or i want to fix this
bug okay well welcome to the developer
community uh
so what if i wanted to this is something
i asked you offline
like a few months ago if i wanted to run
my own code
to um so use comma
as a platform and try to run something
like open pilot
wha what does it take to do that um so
there's a toggle in the settings called
enable ssh
and if you toggle that you can ssh into
your device you can modify the code you
can upload whatever code you want to it
there's a whole lot of people so about
60 of people are running stock comma
about 40 of people are running forks and
there's a community
of there's a bunch of people who
maintain these forks and these forks
support
different cars or they have you know uh
different toggles we try to keep away
from the toggles that are like disabled
driver monitoring but
you know there's some people might want
that kind of thing and like you know
yeah you can it's your car it's your
i'm not here to tell you you know
uh we we have some you know we ban
if you're trying to subvert safety
features you're banned from our discord
i don't want anything to do with you
but there's some forks doing that got it
so you encourage responsible uh forking
yeah yeah some people you know yeah some
people uh like like there's forks that
will do
um some people just like having a lot of
uh readouts on the ui
like a lot of like flashing numbers so
there's forks that do that uh some
people don't like the fact that it
disengages when you press the gas pedal
there's fork that disable that
got it now the the stock experience is
is what
like so it does both lane keeping and
longitudinal control
all together so it's not separate like
it is an autopilot no so
okay um some cars we use the stock
longitudinal control we don't do the
longitudinal control on all the cars
uh some cars the acc's are pretty good
in the cars it's the lane keep that's
atrocious in anything except for
autopilot supercruise
but you know you just turn it on and it
it works what does this engagement look
like yeah so we have i mean i'm very
concerned about mode confusion
i've experienced it on supercruise and
and autopilot where like autopilot like
autopilot disengages
i don't realize that the acc is still on
the
lead car moves slightly over and then
the tesla accelerates to like whatever
my set speed is super fast i'm like
what's going on here um we have
engaged and disengaged and this is
similar to my understanding i'm not a
pilot but my understanding is either the
pilot
is in control or the co-pilot is in
control
and we have the same kind of transition
system either open pilot is engaged or
open pilot is disengaged
engage with cruise control disengage
with either gas break or cancel
you